oh this a Scalia care Cardon oh come and
which is a priestess had a couple
earthquakes last year a 93.5 magnitude
of this earthquake a last night with the
point a death of a climbers and we've
had several ports from all over
Lincolnshire long Xia Rutland and West a
shell of people Filner's and what do
they actually feel what is the sensation
of this well most people and typical
reports describe and it was like a lorry
crashed into the side of the house and
or a steamroller going down the street a
sane and so those of us saw it and
Wendell's our whole house shook
so those are the typical report
sleepiness even yeah pretty scary the
epicenter being near the village of
cutters more 25 miles that is northeast
of Peterborough at 2.9 recorded in
Winchester on Tuesday and do you see the
two things connected and no they're not
connected them mean we thought of
connecting the father's we do get
welfare queens new care we were called
up to maybe 200 some years and athletes
some women you get UK so they're not
connected it's not unnatural feel free
stuff in the UK but most go unnoticed by
the general public because a quick small
earthquake you